[Musica]
vi ricordate 30 anni fa i film di
fantascienza io non ero ancora nata
eppure si immaginavano mondi popolati da
auto volanti e robot ad oggi non ancora
abbiamo ancora progettato le auto
volanti eppure abbiamo inventato
qualcosa di ancora più fenomenale i
droni se ci pensate bene un drone non è
nient'altro che un robot volante
semplici piccoli e leggeri
decisamente meno costosi di qualsiasi
prototipo di robot maneggevoli grazie a
quattro semplici eliche che permettono
di spostarsi in diverse direzioni in
alto in basso a destra a sinistra ma
soprattutto sicuri perché utilizzano
sensori di anti collisione e radar per
evitare qualsiasi tipo di ostacolo la
configurazione dei toni li rende una
tecnologia estremamente duttile e
versatile ed è proprio per questo motivo
che un anno fa oggi di impiegarli
all'interno della mia azienda per voi
idonei potranno essere nient'altro che
un mero strumento ma per me hanno
rappresentato un vero e proprio
risveglio ed è grazie alle potenzialità
dei toni che intendo insieme ai soci
plasmare un futuro nuovo innovativo e
prosperoso dove la tradizione e la
tecnologia la governance
e le imprese possano lavorare assieme
per risvegliare la coscienza collettiva
e assicurare un futuro migliore ai
nostri figli
ora vi starete chiedendo innanzitutto
chi è che non vorrebbe assicurare un
futuro migliore ai propri figli
e inoltre che cosa diamine centrone i
droni
con tutto questo bene se la risposta
alla prima domanda è scontata quella è
la seconda decisamente più complessa ed
è per questo motivo che sono qua oggi
per mostrarvi il che i droni non sono
relegati al nostro immaginario ma sono
una realtà concreta concreta sono già
impiegati in diversi settori lo saranno
sempre di più gli usi sono innumerevoli
dai più banali ai più complessi
ora nell'immaginario comune il zone è
uno strumento di guerra utilizzato per
operazioni di ricognizione e
sorveglianza
tuttavia questo non vuol dire che possa
essere utilizzato per cause ben più
nobili dalla banale ricerca e soccorso
di dispersi in caso di disastri naturali
come slavine e terremoti al trasporto di
organi del ra pianto in località remote
e difficilmente accessibili
voglio darvi un esempio concreto delle
potenzialità che queste piccole macchine
volanti hanno partiamo dall'inizio dal
problema le api esse sono responsabili
per il 75 per cento delle impugnazioni
delle culture del mondo
parliamo di me le ciliegie broccoli
mirtilli ora a causa del cambiamento
climatico e del crescente uso di
pesticidi la popolazione delle api sta
diminuendo drasticamente e ad essere
colpiti non saranno solo gli alimenti
che vi ho appena citato ma anche gli
erbivori che producono latticini e carne
la canola che utilizzata come
biocarburante in molti paesi in via di
sviluppo e addirittura il cotone di cui
sono fatti i vostri vestiti come potete
ben vedere questi dati sono estremamente
allarmanti e nonostante la cattiva
notizia che non ci siano previsioni di
invertire questo trend
alcuni scienziati hanno inventato un
mini drone capace di impallinare i fiori
e così supplire al declino delle api
utilizzando delle semplici crini di
cavallo che vanno a riprodurre il pelo
delle api è un gel che cattura il
polline questi mini droni possono
garantire la sicurezza alimentare in un
futuro così incerto però ovviamente
questo non è un buon motivo per far
morire le api ora questo è solo uno
degli innumerevoli esempi delle
potenzialità dei droni presto entreranno
a far parte delle vostre vite a 360
gradi
a partire dalla frutta e della verdura
che mettete in tavola i droni possono
essere impiegati per controllare la
maturazione dei frutti per spargere
pesticidi in modo localizzato
addirittura per diffonderla semente
senza dimenticare che diventeranno le
nuove auto del futuro e rivoluzionando
completamente le facce della nostra
città soprattutto per quanto riguarda il
trasporto di pacchi via aerea
anziché su ruote il vostro postino di
fiducia sarà un drone li vedrete al mare
quando sarete in vacanza per chi guarda
in spiaggia li utilizzeranno per
controllare i bagnanti e per trasportare
salvagenti in caso di emergenza o
semplicemente li utilizzeranno per
l'intrattenimento
questi sono 2018 droni utilizzati da
intel
a comporre uno spettacolo di luci
[Applauso]
molti obiettori insistono sul rischio
che queste nuove tecnologie comportano
per quanto riguarda rispetto della
privacy
eppure ciò non è dovuto ai doni la
perdita della privacy va imputata alla
curiosità e alla voglia che abbiamo di
condividere ciò che ci piace ciò che non
ci piace dove abitiamo le nostre
abitudini con gli altri semplicemente
non c'è bisogno di un drone o di una
telecamera per spiare cosa fate la sera
nelle vostre case o cosa avete mangiato
a pranzo perché probabilmente l'avrete
già condiviso sui social network
il vero problema è legato alla mancanza
di norme e regole non importa quanto
avanzata sia la tecnologia dei vostri
doni questi non andranno mai assistito a
sostituire l'uomo si sono delle macchine
che servono a renderci la vita più
facile ma sono pur sempre delle macchine
controllate dall uomo
ora la questione non riguarda solo i
droni
ma le nuove tecnologie in generale c'è
bisogno che le istituzioni nei
regolamenti non l'utilizzo al più presto
e che lavorano assieme alle imprese e
agli enti locali al fine di delineare un
piano d'azione conciso ma completo che
possa superare gli ostacoli di una
burocrazia spesso operante e
responsabile del soffocamento di
innumerevoli iniziative e non solo
queste iniziative non sono promosse dai
governi ma sono spesso ostacolate dalla
lentezza dell'apparato burocratico
un esempio eclatante e si tratta della
colpo è socio per span 20 o la
cosiddetta responsabilità sociale di
impresa e la voglia delle grandi e
piccole e medie imprese di avere un
impatto sociale positivo sulla comunità
circostante si tratta di utilizzare una
piccola parte dei propri profitti al
fine di contribuire a preservare il
nostro
pianeta senza il quale non potremmo
sopravvivere in giro per il mondo ci
sono innumerevoli esempi di aziende che
utilizzano proprio i droni per
combattere le grandi sfide di questo
secolo
ad esempio il cambiamento climatico in
california si utilizzano fotocamere
termiche montate sui droni così da conte
contenere gli incendi che ogni estate
bruciano sempre più essere in kenya e in
tanzania i droni vengono impiegati per
salvaguardare la flora e la fauna e
prevenire attività di bracconaggio
mentre in myanmar sono utilizzate per
diffondere la semente per riforestare le
zone costiere abitate da mangrovie
ed è proprio di corpo e socio responso
pelosi che mi occupo all'interno
dell'azienda che ho fondato un anno fa
ad appena 18 anni in silicon valley con
mio fratello che diciamo
mi ha cresciuto a pane idonei
utilizziamo un servizio una rete un
network di piloti di droni per fornire
servizi di sicurezza
ma la parte più interessante è l'idea di
un modello di sviluppo che unisca
assieme il business e la responsabilità
civile
così in caso di emergenza possiamo
offrire il nostro aiuto alla comunità
che ci ha accolti e senza la quale non
potremmo esistere
eppure purtroppo la lentezza e
l'apparato burocratico e la mancanza di
norme ci rallenta e spesso ci impedisce
di intervenire in modo tempestivo ed è
proprio per questo motivo che le
istituzioni devono guidare il processo
di rinnovamento tecnologico con appena
19 anni sulle spalle sono forse ancora
troppo idealista e ottimista all'idea di
poter cambiare
e contribuire al cambiamento necessario
per garantire un futuro ai miei figli o
tutta la vita davanti
eppure sento l'impellenza di agire di
tentare perché so che la mia perché la
speranza che la mia generazione possa e
debba invertire il trend negativo che
ormai stiamo seguendo da troppo tempo è
arrivato il momento del risveglio e non
stiamo parlando di un risveglio
tecnologico o economico parliamo di un
risveglio della coscienza collettiva e
della classe dirigente fronte bore
chiude troppo al fine di lavorare
assieme per dare inizio a un nuovo
rinascimento alla scoperta e alla
salvaguardia della bellezza del nostro
pianeta
[Applauso]
[Musica]